Martha Gellhorn was present during every
single war and conflict around the world
for 60 years she was the only woman to
land on the shores of Normandy during
d-day throughout the course of her life
she was a pacifist and devoted her life
to documenting everything she could with
a sense of perspective and empathy for
the human beings that she was surrounded
by many of calls her the greatest war
correspondents who ever lived
[Music]
born in 1908 in st. Louis Missouri
Martha Gellhorn could not have asked for
two more feminist parents in the world
her mum was that suffragettes and her
dad was a gynecologist so they were all
about female empowerment in 1916 her
mother brought Martha to witness 7,000
people protesting at the Democratic
National Convention for a woman's right
to vote when she was only eight years
old this event it's stuck with her for
the rest of her life and young Martha
never took her vote for granted the
Gellhorn's raised their daughter to know
that she could do anything a man could
do which gave her the confidence that
would help her throughout the rest of
her life
Martha Gellhorn attended Bryn Mawr
College which is a private or girl
school just outside of Philadelphia
she dropped out before she completed her
degree in journalism because she
realized that it was not necessary for
her to start a career in writing
Martha was able to get a few articles
published in a publication called the
New Republic armed with a byline she
applied for a position as a foreign
correspondent in Paris and got a job at
the United Press in 1930 she was 22
years old and living a happy and
romantic life in Paris unfortunately she
became the victim of sexual harassment
work when she refused to sleep with
someone in exchange for a raise
she was fired she continued to live in
Paris and sell her articles to several
magazines including Vogue but by 1934
she decided it was time to move back to
the United States because she felt that
the American people needed someone to
give them a voice President Roosevelt
had created an organization called the
Federal Emergency Relief Administration
and Martha Gellhorn began working for
them she would interview upwards of five
underprivileged families every single
day and heard about their struggles with
poverty disease and a whole lot more
seeing American people live in such
horrible conditions during the Great
Depression it was shocking she wanted to
let the world
know that the so-called American dream
it wasn't as glamorous as everyone
seemed to think it was her articles they
were so moving that Eleanor Roosevelt
herself read them and reached out in
order to become Martha Gellhorn friend
while working at fara
martha encouraged a group of workers to
protest when their boss was treating
them unfairly this escalated into a riot
and windows were broken she was fired
and they tried to label her as a
communist
however the Roosevelts were on her side
and they helped to make sure that the
crooked bosses were removed after losing
her job Martha Gellhorn was invited to
live and work in the White House she
albs Eleanor Roosevelt with writing her
monthly column called my day for a
magazine called
Women's Home Companion however these
topics she was writing with the first
lady were very vapid compared to the
hard-hitting journalism that she was
used to
Gellhorn thanks that Roosevelt's for
their kindness but she wanted to move on
with her career she published a book
called the trouble I've seen which
described the suffering of the American
people in the Great Depression
deep down she knew that she wanted to
use her writing to help people and
eventually she would get her wish
[Music]
even though Martha Gellhorn had already
accomplished so much during her early
writing career much of that is
overshadowed by the fact that she fell
in love with the famous author Ernest
Hemingway in 1936 Martha Gellhorn was in
Key West Florida on vacation with their
parents when she decided to get a drink
at a bar called sloppy joes at first she
was taken aback by a loud and dirty man
who was telling wild stories and acting
like the center of attention she locked
eyes with the men across the room and
realized that this was the famous Ernest
Hemingway he approached her Aran's they
began to strike up a conversation even
though he did not recognize her face it
turns out that he had in fact read her
articles and did indeed her first book
they both have a very similar writing
style in the way that they cut out all
of the flowery language in favor of
getting to the point they also deeply
cared about the struggles of other human
beings by the end of their first
conversation it was clear that they had
chemistry and they wanted to see each
other again
anyway told her that he was headed to
the Spanish Civil War to write the
script of a documentary called this
Spanish earth who eventually narrate the
movie as well because the actor they
hired couldn't get the cadence exactly
right
Martha Gellhorn never written on the
wall before and she secured a contract
with Colliers magazine and followed him
there soon after there were several
other men on the documentary crew as
well as other reporters who lived and
work together at the Hotel Florida in
Madrid no one can be sure exactly when
their relationship escalated from
co-workers to lovers that in a lot of
ways they truly were the perfect couple
there was perhaps no other man alive on
the planet who was manly enough to
handle Martha Gellhorn strength and she
could keep up with Hemingway's need for
adventure over the next four years
gallon and Hemingway continued their
affair while he was still married to his
second wife by the way poorly and
feather alright so before you go calling
Martha Gellhorn nasty names in the
comments of this video you should know a
bit about Ernest Hemingway's first two
marriages Hemingway's first wife was
named Hadley Richardson after he became
the best-selling author in 1926 with the
Sun Also Rises he started receiving a
lot of attention and suddenly he had to
deal with fangirls who fell in love with
his masculine writing style however he
was still very poor and he could hardly
pay for his basic needs a woman called
Pauline Pfeiffer grew up spoiled by
wealthy parents and she secured posh gig
writing fashion columns for the magazine
she often wrote in the first person
about attending lavish parties and
fashion shows that was you
getting everything in life that she
wanted and Hemingway was added to that
wish list she swept in claiming that she
wanted to be best friends with Hadley
Richardson the two women had almost
nothing in common and it was truly odd
that this wealthy heiress was suddenly
so interested in this impoverished
couple paulien Pfeffer seduced Hemingway
and became pregnant with his child he
entered divorce happily and he married
Pauline but spend the rest of his career
bitterly writing about how much he
actually hated her so no one really felt
very sorry for ever when she ended up
being cheated on to in fact most feel
that Martha Gellhorn was his true love
and took marrying two of the wrong women
before he could find her that time in
Spain it was exhilarating Galan founds
this new love and compassion for the
people who were affected by the war she
and Hemingway both worked in China to
cover the events of the second
sino-japanese war from there she covered
the Nazi occupation of czechoslovakia
and finland and they were not working
together on assignment they would write
letters to one another and only meet up
when their schedules aligned they had an
affair for a total of three years and
the only group more and more convinced
that this was the woman that he truly
wanted to marry in 1939 Hemingway
purchased a 15 acre estate in Cuba for
Martha and he to live on together after
getting his new life settled he
officially divorced his second wife and
he and Martha were married in 1940 even
though they now had this beautiful house
together in a tropical paradise Martha
continued to travel the world as a war
correspondent
Hemingway continued to write his novels
alone as his typewriter and went fishing
and drinking with the locals he was so
lonely that he got a very strange hobby
of breeding six toed cats he bred so
many of them that they soon over ran his
estate
for a few years Gellhorn and Hemingway
they seem to be living a very happy life
together in Cuba enjoying the beaches in
the sunshine unfortunately it became
toxic when Hemingway began to ask Martha
if she was ever gonna settle down and
become more nurturing this is when
things got a bit awkward Hemingway was
used to going on his wild adventures
then he could come home to housewives
like Hadley and Pauline who were happy
to cook clean and look after the
children
he knew that being a war correspondent
was Martha's passion but he figured that
after getting married she would calm
down and become a novelist who did all
of the typical duties of a wife and a
mother but her motivation for being on
the frontlines it never went away and
she did not want to have any children
with him Hemingway already had several
children from his previous marriages but
they came a point when he felt that he
was truly missing starting a new family
with her
but Martha felt that it was her duty to
be a witness to the atrocities of war
instead of staying at home where it was
safe if nobody puts it down on the
record anywhere than the monsters win
totally it must be someplace on the
record because otherwise they can get
away with anything
does it stop anything I don't feel that
anything I have been done is in use but
at least it is better than silence
because if he was silence they can
rewrite it any way they want they can
make it look great afterwards so there
is a point in the record aside from his
hobby of being a crazy cat lady
Hemingway continued his midlife crisis
by getting into the habit of hunting for
German u-boats off the coast of Cuba he
never actually caught any but he still
filled his boat with grenades because he
had the mindset that maybe one day he
could be the hero who demolished a Nazi
submarine when the news came that the
Allies were about to storm the beaches
of Normandy Martha did not waste any
time securing a press pass from Colliers
magazine she was friends with the
British author Roald Dahl and he helped
her to get set up with a sponsorship to
have a plane ticket paid for by the
Royal Air Force so long as she wrote
positively about them in her piece for
whatever reason whether it was anger
jealousy or pure spite Hemingway marched
right in to Collier's and demanded to
take a press spot since he was the
famous novelist they couldn't refuse the
opportunity to publish one of his pieces
they gave him Martha's plane ticket and
the press pass
Martha was infuriated by his betrayal
but she was still determined to make her
way into the war zone she dressed up as
a navy nurse and stowed away in the
bathroom of a ship that was headed to
so Hemingway was boarding a plane Martha
Gellhorn was struggling to get to Europe
by seep once he arrived in Paris
Hemingway began partying almost
immediately and he decided to work
together with a ragtag group of war
correspondents who were on a mission to
liberate the Hotel Ritz in Paris this
used to be his favorite bar in the city
and he wanted nothing more than to get
into some Nazi fighting action it was at
this point that Hemingway also began
cheating on Gellhorn with a woman he met
called Mary Welsh finally after stowing
away on a ship and risking her life
Martha Gellhorn arrived at the harbor in
Liverpool ready to confront her husband
she heard that he was in the hospital in
London because it gotten into a car
accident while drunk driving when she
found Hemingway he seemed perfectly a
fine aside from a gash in his head which
was wrapped in bandages he was drinking
whiskey surrounded by fans who were
hanging on his every word mother decided
not to waste any more time or energy on
Hemingway
she went to Normandy and snuck away into
the frontlines of d-day since Hemingway
still had a press pass Gellhorn had no
choice that dresses a nurse and helped
to carry injured soldiers on a stretcher
on and off the battlefield
she paid close attention to her
surroundings making mental notes so that
she could write them down later
she stayed in Europe and made her way to
the Dachau concentration camp
Martha was one of the very first and
only journalists to arrive on the scene
when it was liberated by the Allies no
one could have ever anticipated the
horrors that unfolded there Martha
Gellhorn was mere feet away from the
starved bodies of the Jewish prisoners
lying next to the dead German soldiers
who were perfectly well-fed she
describes a horrific scene of bodies
with shaved heads that was so thin their
ages and genders were indistinguishable
from one another she could smell the
rotting of their corpses the last
shipment of prisoners had arrived from
Buchenwald to Dachau but the Nazis
locked the train doors from the outside
and left them to die slowly of
starvation
galvan describes a Polish prisoner they
found inside of a train car one man had
survived he was found in a pile of the
debt now he stood on the bones that were
his legs and talked and suddenly wept
everyone it's dead on the plane ride out
of Germany Martha sat together with a
group of stunned American prisoners of
war who had been rescued from DeKalb she
wrote no one looked out the window as we
flew her for Germany no one wanted to
see Germany again they turned away from
it in sickness everything about it was
evil the men sat in silence for a long
time until one soldier said no one will
believe us after bearing witness to some
of the most sickening atrocities in
human history it only reminded Martha
Gellhorn why her job to expose the truth
was so important she knew that she
needed to continue to devote her life to
this course on a flight back home she
must have reflected on how petty all of
the arguments with her husband truly
were none of it was worth it anymore
when she was back in the United States
she filed for divorce from Hemingway
he was absolutely furious and wrote
letters to her saying that she was a
phony and pretentious [ __ ] then he set
out to ruin her reputation just like he
had with his second wife their divorce
was so uncivilized she scarcely wanted
to speak to him or about him ever again
during interviews later in life Martha
Gellhorn refused to talk about her
marriage with Hemingway I've been a
writer for over 40 years I was a writer
before I met him and I was a writer
after I left him
why should I merely be a footnote in his
life Hemingway would go on to get
married to his mistress Mary Welsh she
would be his fourth and final wife and
she had absolutely no problem fitting
into the role of a homemaker
unfortunately even though he got the
sort of wife he wanted Hemingway
continued to struggle
being happy he would eventually commit
suicide in 1961
following her divorce from and stemming
way Martha Gellhorn decided to remain
single for several years and focused on
her career in 1949 she visited Rome to
see children in an orphanage who had
lost limbs or become blind because of
accidentally stepping on landmines
she wrote a piece called the children
pay the price for The Saturday Evening
Post a heart was breaking for these
children so she chose to adopt a little
boy called George Sandy Alexander since
she was an American woman trying to
adopt an Italian boy she had to write
several letters to the Roosevelts asking
for the help to bring sandy back to the
United States so that she could provide
a better life for him however her busy
schedule prevented her from being a
full-time mother most of the time sandy
was left in the care of Martha's parents
and he was later sent to boarding school
after taking some time to be on her own
Martha began dating several successful
men who were doctors businessman and
journalists eventually she married the
editor of Time magazine TS Matthews in
1954 but they got a divorce in 1963
after two failed marriages she never
tried again the lifestyle she chose of
traveling to far-off places to put her
life in danger was very difficult to
balance with being a wife or a mother so
she remained single traveling the world
and reporting from the front lines
because she truly felt compelled that
this was what she was supposed to be
doing with her life when we talk about
honoring people in the Armed Forces the
word sacrifice is often used for Martha
Gellhorn she truly did sacrifice
everything to be a war correspondent she
gave up her marriage as the chance to
have children and precious time spent
with friends and family instead of
living for herself she chose an
existence that gave a voice to the
downtrodden
all around the globe Martha often
traveled alone with nothing to her name
except a single suitcase of her bare
essentials she wrote that loneliness was
far more difficult than anything else in
one of her letters she wrote I was used
to having only myself cold and hard as
that is I could live with it and now I
wait for a voice a face a body that is
not mine does not
in any case wait as I do nor share this
homesickness after witnessing so many
wars there was nothing that Martha
Gellhorn hated more than a government
who was power-hungry
in her book the face of war she give us
a breakdown of just how much money the
United States spends on nuclear weapons
and at the time she wrote the book it
amounted to over a billion dollars a day
so much could be done with that money to
help the poor and the sick and yet it
all goes into these
Evans that could lead to the destruction
of the human race for her the straw that
broke the camel's back was witnessing
firsthand what Americans were doing
during the Vietnam War they discussed it
her so much that she couldn't bring
herself to continue living in the United
States she moved to London which is
where she spent the rest of her life in
1998 she was 89 years old and almost
completely blind
she was also suffering from a very own
cancer she was sick and barely hanging
on to life so she decided to commit
suicide by ingesting a cyanide capsule
and left everything she had to her
adopted son sandy ten years later in
1999 the Martha Gellhorn prize for
journalism was established in order to
win the award a walker respondin must
accomplish reporting that is essentially
a human story that penetrates the
established version of events and
illuminates an urgent issue the
unpalatable truth validated by powerful
facts that exposes establishment conduct
and its propaganda even after witnessing
some of the darkest parts of humanity
through the course of her career she
never gave up hope that people can be
good I do not hope for a world at peace
to all of its all the time I do not
believe in the perfectibility of man
which is what would be required for
world peace I only believe in the human
race
I believe the human race must continue
for years to come Martha Gellhorn will
continue to inspire war correspondents
everywhere to do just that
get on the grounds find the truth of
what people are experiencing and tell
the world by understanding one another
we can only get closer to remaining in a
world where peace exists and Wars are
few and far between so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos just like
this four times a week also let me know
what you thought of this video use the
comments all that good stuff and I'll
see you next time